we all know parenthood is very expensive
and it would be really difficult for
parents to afford to put something away
now the good news is that there are some
very useful savings vehicles out there
the junior isa for individual savings
account is a very tax efficient way to
put some money away for a child as just
as a parent gets a tax-free allowance
every year that they can shelter within
this savings account wrapper each child
gets an allowance of 4 000 pounds a year
now even if you cannot afford to put
that four thousand pounds away if you
put a small amount away say a hundred
pounds a month and we assume that that
money is locked away for the 18 years of
the child's life because that is the
nature of a junior isa
and you're investing in the stock market
on funds and we're assuming a growth
rate of around five percent there's a
very good chance that that investment
small as it may be will grow and grow
and grow and by the time your child
reaches age 18 you would have sheltered
away around 30 000 pounds which will go
a long way to funding their debt and
towards that first deposit on a property